all right we're almost there aren't we
most of you too I've walked around 2i
finished let's give this a shot I'm
following the pattern right so when I
look at this second row I'm not taking
away three every time as I go from right
to left one might take you away to right
and that's because I'm in the two row so
I'm going to complete here take away two
to take away 6 in my one row I'm going
to get these numbers but now something
weird happens here have a look what's
going on when I go from this to this and
this to this and this to this am i still
getting smaller i'm looking for a might
hold on negative 3 to negative 2 [ __ ]
choose a bigger number than this right
and negative 1 is bigger than eat you so
what am i doing from right to left
Tyrion I'm heading right I go ad one and
add 1 then add 1 ok so therefore if I
continue going this way I'm going to add
one every time add 1 add 1 everyone this
is getting pretty colorful and busy
isn't it right so these numbers will
fill them in from right to left i'm
going to have one then two then three
just stop for a second put your pens
down this is we hi I'm can be used what
does this mean like just this corner in
here what's going on here what mothers
are my miles find out what numbers are
welcome
I'm only two negatives how come not
gonna be positive and they're getting
really really big why would two
negatives become a positive because it
unanimously planet this is what we
looked at in addition and subtraction
wasn't it it's what we were cutting up
okay if you're getting a negative and
another negative it's a little bit like
taking away something that's having you
the whole thing will go up just like the
house did right so that's why these
numbers over here are positive they're
going to keep on getting more positive
it's got the whole thing right I'm going
to increase by two in the next row and
then I'm going to increase by a three in
the bottom okay so this is a bit strange
integers are a bit weird right when you
have a pair of numbers like this we
looked at this in the review questions
right that's two negatives two negatives
right what do I do what picture should i
have in my head when I'm doing this we
drew the picture before right what kind
of diagram goodies my rule I'd I'm going
to draw a number line right i'm gonna
start at me 0 and we started to get to
and i'm going to move when you go one
two three four and that's where i end up
yes does that make sense so when i'm
adding subtracting a movie yes charlie
yes you may but when i multiply when i'm
multiplying something different is
happening right I'm feeling in times
tables so here is a summary for you okay
let me make it a bit bigger for you mmm
and this allows you to put into your
book and you should stick in that sheet
once it's completed and you can jot this
down right in
summary each of these represents a
different relationship for the different
kinds of numbers you're doing in your
table right we knew you multiplex your
positive together you're going to get a
nun positive right that was simple if
you must play a net a positive and a
negative again this is the second corner
of the table we feel that you're going
to get a needy right all those numbers
all those numbers over there they were
negative right if you go down the
direction and negative and a positive
still going to multiply to an idiot but
the weirdest part was this last bit that
we filled in in the corner of the scroll
up just a teeny bit if you've got two
negatives we often call this a double
negative because double just means two
of them right a double negative becomes
a positive right just like we saw it up
so in adding it's attractive this is
really really important because people
get confused about this quite easily
great if your two negatives they get
more negatives you see that because you
should think of that moving on another
life but if you're multiplied as you see
tomorrow when we do division multiple
multiply your division suicides in the
city boy it's different question yes
please underground so when adding
subtracting this is the picture in your
hair okay but we're multiplying dividing
what's my admire about ten moves right
times tables and there's a very
different picture involved so don't get
them confused
and that's why two negatives here are
they multiply to a positive okay if you
have some college I'll be really helpful
so you can really really distinguish
these two things from each other because
they're quite closely related it easy to
mix them up which is why I'm going to
finish you up and just put up the high
one in a second people ask me before I
do I have to draw it on the line you
know this review questions do I have to
throw it up one have to do but I really
like doing it like I've been doing these
I fear these four decades now I'm surely
right I'll tell her I'm doing that and I
still do them so I can visualize what's
going on and not mix out what's going on
here with this okay adding subtracting
multiplying different kinds of ideas